leute ich hab nur zehn minuten zeit
aufzunehmen und dann kommt
servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute wieder eine
doppel face camp challenge mit dem oral
b spielen und link man heute ist
vielleicht der ich will nicht sagen
stressigste weil es eigentlich kulac
ursachen sind aber derzeit nicht eng
getaktet tag bei mir seit langem
ich kann euch kurz mal erzählen wie es
ist also heute morgen um halb acht
aufgestanden ab 8 uhr videos geschnitten
dann 10 im büro direkt nach dem büro ins
fitness studio direkt haben
fitnessstudios ihren pc und aufnehmen
und gleich direkt weiter zu einen dingen
und ja die partie heute spielen ist die
challenge die wahl stehen bleibt man
stehen und friese ok stehen bleiben ja
ja wie viele items aus der ersten klasse
genommen kann nur an und war schon
mehreren kisten dann schmeißt alles weg
einheiten pro kiste ist die heutige
challenge und ich nehme die erfolge
musiker einheiten pro kiste doch obwohl
auch der erzähler ein vergessen die
challenge rechtzeitig an zu sagen ich
nehme mal äpfel raus ein alter bock ösi
des heutigen tages wieder eine doppel
facebook mit marty hat euch ja gut
gefallen denn die habe ich so am
liebsten mit matt auf danke ich einfach
zu verstehen ist wirklich so ich habe
ich werde hier niemals mit irgendein
andere youtuber so gut verstehen beim
eigenen bruder
doch ganz normal wer bestimmt bogen
wobei eben normal ist das nicht man
sollte auf jeden fall vorüber sein
bitte es gibt hier auch entweder ich
glaube es gibt bestimmt auch so mittel
dinge aber entweder richtig zwischen
geschwistern oder man mag sich wohl aber
ich hatte heute auch im stressigen tag
also mit serial steuererklärung das
lieblingsthema das dann schulzeit und
koordinieren ich habe ja noch ein
anderes projekt was
für youtube als was muss bei youtube zu
tun hat barbara can tell you that we are
the world on the block heute nämlich
heraus er sagt das noch mal
und da hast du keine neue skate ich habe
einen der gehen etwa meist privat bist
du ich bin bei muttern fünf gerade
angekommen wo ich weiß es gar nicht ich
bin beim modul 6 grad angekommen ja ich
bin der flyers ist einfach es ist
einfach zu schnell aber in das problem
ist ich kenne mich halt einfach nicht
aus hier bei den modulen mainzer kennen
wir ganz module nicht dafür müsste er
nicht schenker wegs muss man sagen kenne
die meisten doch eigentlich schon ach ja
was für ein rotz wird so eine so eine
falle
profikoch wenig verschätzt wer bin ich
eigentlich bin ich wenigstens kräftig
sah ich habe das gefühl dass ich nicht
bin
das klingt irgendwie senna ersetzt der
rechts im snowboard leute nicht dass er
ich denke worüber reden wir später recht
aber das scoreboard
du bist ich glaube ich bin in alex wie
ich bin doch cryptics er tatsächlich wer
jetzt nicht gedacht so jetzt muss man
hier drauf ok weiß nicht was sie aus der
kiste nehmen immer nur eitel enchantment
tables erscheint
warum nein ich schwöre warum das war
dass ich verrückt runter enchantment
table ja klar
in scharmützeln gute sache würde ich so
gut aber wenn man nicht so viele sachen
draußen im darf dann ist natürlich auch
trick jeder kanzler dennoch noch mehr
tricky uncharmant war dass ich meine du
darfst also du darfst jetzt wenn du also
drei models donnerstag 3 bartels
rausnehmen
oft schicken ich war die ganze zeit
runter das sind ja ja auch an den
seltsamsten stellen man das hatte ich
komisch du bist noch bei 6 oder ich bin
immer noch bei 56 ist etwas länger das
modul das ist so modul was ich nehme
eisen stiefel oder eisenachs heißen
stiefel ich spekuliere darauf dass
jemand steinfurt bekommen
jetzt hier nicht runterfallen es wäre
sehr ärgerlich kann ziemlich weit
gekommen
wieso kann man in einem zaun hängen
bleiben wie hängen bleiben wie man sie
also wenn man parallel zu den zaun läuft
das der ein verlangsamter so ein scheiß
ja klar
also wieder ganz normale wand wenn du
sprint ist dann macht er die langsam das
video normale band für dich da manha
block machte ich glaub ich langsamer
wenn du dagegen sprint ist dagegen
spreche jetzt nebendran goldhahn mich
nämlich machten gleich lang
ich weiß nicht worüber du tags also ich
weiß nicht über welche module hengst
gerade ehrlich gesagt 25 noch immer aber
ich habe es jetzt geschafft
okay das ist gut das ist gut ich brauche
gerade beim modul acht rein und dieser
alex macht mir ganz schön dampf der ist
auch ziemlich flotter rechts und
überholt werden dass alle erholt genau
hier ist das stein schule was ich haben
wollte das paar kurz weg gespannt wird
aber sowieso erst das nette leute
sag ich mal so falsch jetzt ob alex hier
lang kommt oder auf jeden fall erst
recht also ich glaube auch blatt match
das dritte spannender weil dann wird
sich erst zeigen wie gut wir performen
mit den knappen items weder haben
ich hab einen trick für die passage die
kann ich nicht normal abermals
normalerweise verfahren wir hatten nur
in knappen hosen ja der trick ist
nämlich dass man da auf diese kleine
treppen stufen runter geht
da ist man nämlich irgendwie schneller
ich bin aber konzentriert ich spiele oft
gut ich bei mir lästig kastration gerade
nach glaube ich so wie es immer ist
immer eine stelle hängen bleibt peter
vormachten eigentlich alles so nah ist
echt oder machtlos und bisschen ja voll
erkennen
darüber nachdenken aber er vergibt hier
das ist gut für mich das ist ein trick
nein mein alter was war dass man einen
jungen 1
wir müssen es packen komm schon mancher
schon auf dem auf dem blog jedes gibt's
doch nicht
auf dem da das ist ein echtes einzig
schwierige dann also der tat dass man
hier so läuft genau
ich hab's geschafft dann haben es hier
so jetzt habe ich es ok das ist mein
trick und man fühlt sich nicht so als
wenn man schneller in minecraft aber man
ist es scheinbar mannschaft den sprung
an eigentlich sie immer so okay
natürlich eisenhändler doch bist du bei
modul 8 dann kann ich dir zeigen oder
sagen oh ja ich bin beim modul 7 das der
trick den den den ich meine der wirtin
modul acht relevant relevant echt ich
dein rede von hybrid aus
deswegen passen
wie hat sich natürlich nicht leute die
pfeile nehme ich mit ich hatte natürlich
soll ich sonst was
ok ich glaube hier lange man ich bin so
konzentriert konzentriert und zack sieht
es ganz gut aus dass mit den seeländer
sagst du ist das wo man aufpassen muss
nein leute weil ich jetzt richtig heiß
kalt gewesen hätte ich natürlich auf die
die abu spekuliert am ende mehr keine
buhs geholt aber so dreist war ich mal
nicht schnell kippen
und jetzt zeigt sich wie gut wir
performen mit der einheiten pro kiste
bier nicht dass michael ikrath
wir sind ein team ins verbindet
natürlich okay
entsprechend gutes equipment ich werde
jetzt auf jeden fall taktisch kämpfen
müssen mir meine angeln einsetzen es
gerade eben diesen triolen bei der
arbeits typ ist gut eine bitte der alex
typen tut ja der hat auch susanne riesch
ist glaube ich sogar das ist er damit am
hut mit 16 als er was ich habe schon
zwei leben verloren
ja es geschehen ein
victoria's secret hier würde ich dir
auch ein mittel geben natürlich ganz
bewusst war alles kalkuliert jetzt nicht
irgendwie absichtlich zu töten
du weißt du weißt was meine oma würden
welche flug ist eigentlich of the mr
nice hacker wenn wir leute töten
da von den einheiten pro kiste würde ich
sagen ach verlangt das sind ja auch
kisten ja ja klar ich habe mir glaube
ich nur die äpfel gerade ihn
rausgenommen und als dieser alex neid
ich habe gedacht oh gott ich bin was ist
bei dir los du bist auch wieder eine
lobby oder leute ich hab nur zehn
minuten zeit aufzunehmen und dann kommt
playmate i dig eingeschalten server
gebacken kriegen und machen so eine wehr
sollen damit klar kommen ohne wird euch
alle
so leute rentner jemanden der auf dem
land zum strich geht die blicke in der
landschaft tschuldigung mord verfluchen
ich hoffe es hat sich nicht so leute das
war's von der heutigen challenge tanke
schon ab lady für die freundliche
unterstützung gibt an dich auch dann
bitte bitte der kürzlich von herzen
john lee